salud en directo américa de france 24 me
acompaña en el estudio marina sardina
marina muy buena mañana de martes hoy
vamos a volver a hablar de la llamada
viral de viruela del mono y vamos a
hacer un recuento sobre esta enfermedad
ya declarada como sabemos por la
organización mundial de la salud como
emergencia de salud pública importancia
internacional
le pregunté entonces que realmente es la
viruela del mono bueno raúl buenos días
y si vamos a seguir hablando de la
viruela del mundo porque en es una
enfermedad que sigue muy patente hoy en
hoy ahí está en boca de todos la viruela
del mono o la viruela química es una
zoonosis viral es decir es un virus
transmitido a los humanos por los
animales si bien se desconoce el origen
animal exacto se cree que es un roedor
en parte también está desconocido porque
es una enfermedad poco estudiada y esto
es principalmente porque la mayor
cantidad de los casos se han registrado
en países de áfrica con escasos recursos
para investigar si bien se si bien es un
virus similar a la viruela humana sus
síntomas son menos letales y tienen unas
dolencias más leves y menos contagiosas
recordemos también que la viruela humana
se radicó en los años 80 en cuanto al
patógeno pertenece al género [__] pop
[__] pop virus de la familia posibilidad
un virus de adn de doble cadena envuelto
hay dos claros genéticos o linajes
distintos raúl y geográficamente también
están geolocalizados en dos regiones
áfrica central históricamente más mortal
y contagio contagioso y el claro de
áfrica occidental este es de menor
virulencia y es el que habría desatado
el brote fuera de áfrica veamos una
cronología de la viruela del mono el
virus fue descubierto si bien fue
descubierto en el 58 el primer caso
reportado en humanos se detectó en
1970 en un menor en república
democrática del congo desde entonces de
notificaron casos en 11 países africanos
durante los últimos 50 años ha habido
brotes esporádicos principalmente en
estas naciones africanas el 7 de mayo de
1000 de 2022 se detectó el primer caso
de viruela química en reino unido a un
paciente que había viajado recientemente
a nigeria tras los casos de reino unido-
rauch empezaron a detectar casos en
españa francia en suiza o bélgica el 19
de este mismo mes se detecta en eeuu en
américa el primer contagio de viruela
símica y el 23 de julio con con unos
16.000 casos en 75 países lado ms
declara la emergencia de salud pública
de importancia internacional
que no depende tanto del número de
contagios sino como declaró como dijo
lala o ms se debe también al crecimiento
de la transmisión el impacto en la salud
pública debido a que la enfermedad pasó
a ser de transmisión autóctona fuera de
países endémicos el 29 de julio brasil
reportó la primera muerte fuera de
áfrica y ese mismo día raúl españa
también detectó su primer fallecimiento
por viruela cínica haremos ahora marina
de los países en que está presente esta
enfermedad hasta el momento pues como
decíamos la enfermedad es endémica en
áfrica pero ya está presente en al menos
78 naciones fuera de este continente
veamos en este mapa donde están
localizados hay más de 23 mil 200 casos
confirmados y otros cientos más
pendientes de confirmación hasta el
momento brasil
india perú y
españa han detectado fallecimientos con
un total de 5 pero a la vez hay que
recordar raúl que los casos se están
registrando los mayores casos en áfrica
y también los más letales con el mayor
número de muertes a la vez que es el
continente que menos recursos tiene para
su prevención
marina también le quiero preguntar
cuáles son los síntomas digamos o como
uno puede saber que tendría esta vida
del mono cómo detectarlo sobre todo
decíamos que se trata de la misma rama
de la viruela humana pero este sus casos
sus síntomas son mucho más leves no en
la mayoría de los casos se curan en un
plazo de dos a cuatro semanas sin
necesidad de tratamiento las personas
que en fez se enferman suelen tener
fiebre alta dolor de cabeza dolor de
garganta dolor muscular inflamación de
ganglios linfáticos y agotamiento muchos
después de la fiebre desarrollan
lesiones cutáneas o pústulas erupciones
vesículas o sarpullidos en la piel los
síntomas suelen aparecer entre los 6 y
los 13 días del contagio del primer
contagio y suelen irse de forma normal
sin necesidad de un tratamiento hablas
de contagio marina le pregunto entonces
cómo se llega a transmitir sabemos
además que ha habido una fuerte polémica
por la estigmatización que hay entre los
hombres que tienen sexo con hombres
porque parece que es la población como
más vulnerable la población donde más se
ha propagado esta enfermedad
así es el virus de la viruela del mono
se puede propagar de persona a persona a
través del contacto físico muy cercano a
las lesiones con estas lesiones o
pústulas infecciosas que decíamos antes
también al tocar artículos contaminados
ropa ropa de cama sin embargo también a
través se puede contagiar a través de
gotas respiratorias grandes de saliva
producidas al toser de forma directa y
en un contacto muy prolongado algunos
estudios han detectado restos del virus
en el semen y la mucosa rectal pero
todavía no se ha confirmado que sea una
enfermedad de transmisión sexual de
cualquier forma los casos más frecuentes
de esta infección de este brote de
transmisión es estando entre parejas que
tienen sexo con parejas de su mismo sexo
existen otras vías de transmisión como
ejemplo de madres a luz al feto a través
de la placenta y la o&m se informó de
que el 98% de las personas contagiadas
son hombres menores de 40 años que han
tenido relaciones íntimas con otros
hombres pero también hay casos en
mujeres y niños y bien pues son la
minoría por eso
como decías no hay que estigmatizar ni
propiciar otro virus que es letal que es
el virus de la homofobia y de la
discriminación como vienen alertando
activistas y también la misma o ms este
brote de la viruela del mono pese a no
ser una enfermedad de transmisión sexual
debe también ser una ventana para hablar
de este tipo de enfermedades que están
altamente estigmatizadas charo marina y
por eso es importante como siempre
tratamos de hacerlo aquí en directo
américa en nuestro canal y por supuesto
nuestra sección de salud informar de
forma rigurosa sobre un tema que todavía
está en desarrollo y también
investigación que poco se sabe al
respecto así como la vacuna cuéntanos
entonces hablando de vacunas
tratamientos que hay para este hábito
del mono aquí ha habido un poquito de
confusión existe una única vacuna para
la viruela del mono disponible en el
mercado es inba mex como se conoce en
europa
guineos como se conoce en eeuu está
fabricada por la fom farmacéutica danesa
bavaria nordic y se trata de una vacuna
no replicante de tercera generación se
cree que es efectiva en el 85% de sus
cut de los casos pero hay dudas sobre
que esta cifra pues sobre esta cifra
ampliamente réplica no es exactamente la
misma vacuna que se utilizó hace cuatro
décadas para tratar la viruela humana
pero estas dosis que recibieron esas
personas en aquel momento pues ayudaría
a mitigar los síntomas tendría una estas
personas tendrían una mayor protección
el organismo de salud internacional no
recomienda la vacunación masiva por el
momento en parte por la escasez de las
dosis hasta el momento sólo hay 16.000
coma 4 millones de vacunas disponibles y
al menos 35 naciones están compitiendo
por concebir las la por conseguir la
mayor cantidad de inyecciones esto
también se recomienda que las personas
de mayor alto riesgo como decíamos
personas que tienen sexo con personas de
su mismo sexo pues se vacunen también
como el personal sanitario de primera
línea o contactos cercanos confirmados
también hombres jóvenes pues como
decíamos que han tenido relaciones con
otros hombres américa latina y áfrica
pese a que en áfrica es endémica la
enfermedad todavía no ha recibido
ninguna dosis y esto nos dice que pues
deja ver la patente inequidad en el
acceso a las vacunas que siga habiendo y
que también lo vimos con el cob y 19no
ms dijo recientemente algo al respecto
señalando que la salud es un derecho y
no un privilegio
access to live el acceso a herramientas
de prevención pruebas y tratamientos
salvan vidas ya sea vih con 19 o viruela
del mono con demasiada frecuencia
depende del azar es un lugar de
nacimiento color de piel sexo cuánto
ganan los rocieros quien por how much
war de esta manera entonces llegamos al
final de esta sección de salud por el
día de hoy marina muchísimas gracias por
toda la información nosotros pasamos a
saludar a las mentes para hablar de
deportes